company a is offering $10,000 for the
first month and will increase the amount
each month by $5,000 Company B is
offering $500 for the first month and
will double their payment each month for
which monthly payment will company B's
payment first exede company a's payment
so pause this video and try to work that
out alright let's work this out together
so let's let me set up a little bit of a
table so this is going to be first
column I'm going to have is month first
column is month second column is how
much company a is going to pay and then
third column let's think about how much
Company B is going to pay well they tell
us a few things they say company a is
offering $10,000 for the first month so
in month one company a is offering
$10,000 we'll assume well I'll just
write the dollars there and then Company
B is offering $500 for the first month
$500 for the first month but then they
tell us company a is offering we'll
increase the amount each month by $5,000
so month two will be 5,000 more will get
to $15,000 a month three will get two
will get to $20,000 for will get to
$25,000 five I think you get the point
we'll get to $30,000 six will get to
$35,000 seven will get to $40,000 let me
scroll down a little bit month a they'll
stop there month eight we will get to
$45,000 and let me just extend these
lines a little bit now let's think about
was going to happen with Company B
Company B is offering 500 for the first
month it'll double their payment each
month so the second month is going to be
double that so that's going to be $1,000
then we're double that again
$2,000 we're in double that again
four thousand dollars double that again
sixteen thousand dollars double that
again
thirty-two thousand dollars double that
the Louvre I skipped one
I went from four thousand two sixteen
thousand four thousand eight thousand
dollars then we doubled it again sixteen
thousand dollars again thirty-two I
sound like my two-year-old again
thirty-two thousand dollars then we get
to sixty-four thousand dollars and at
that point something interesting happens
actually good that I went to the eighth
month because every month before the
eighth month company age payment was
higher until at eight month and that
eight month company B is going to pay
more so first we can just answer their
question for which monthly payment will
company B's payment first exceed Company
A's payment well that is month eight
month eight and there's a broader lesson
going on here you might recognize that
the rate at which company A's payment is
increasing is linear every month it
increases by the same amount so plus
five thousand plus five thousand it
increases by five thousand the same
amount Company B is increasing
exponentially it's increasing by the
same factor every time so we're
multiplying by the same value every time
we're multiplying by two we're
multiplying by two multiplying by two
and so there's actually a very
interesting thing here that you can
actually make the general statement that
an exponential function will one
something that is exponentially
increasing will eventually always
surpass something that is linearly
increasing and it doesn't matter what
the initial situation is and it also
doesn't even matter that rate of
exponential increase it will eventually
always pass up something that's
increasing linearly and you could think
about that visually if you like if I
were to draw a visual function a linear
function so this is x-axis this is the
y-axis a linear function well it's going
to be described by a line so it could
look something like this
linear function is always going to be a
line of some slope and an exponential
function even though it might start a
little bit slower it's eventually it's
eventually going to pass up the linear
function and this is going to be the
case even if the linear function has a
pretty high slope or pretty high
starting point if it's something like
that and even if the exponential
function is starting pretty slow it will
eventually and even if it's compounding
or growing relatively slow but
exponentially of scoring two percent or
three percent
it still will eventually pass up the
linear function which is pretty cool